monsieur le Premier ministre mes chers
collègues Monsieur le Premier Ministre
vous tentez d'incarner un changement
mais la seule nouveauté c'est que ce
remaniment marque l'ancrage dans votre
nouveau monde de casse du service public
un monde fait pour les riches un monde
d'oppression pour les salariés un monde
qui exclut au lieu de rassembler cette
politique génère une crise démocratique
profonde d'ailleurs le président de la
République n'a toujours pas de majorité
absolue à l'Assemblée nationale cette
question n'est ni politicienne ni
secondaire c'est le socle du
fonctionnement de nos institutions vous
ne pouvez plus faire jouer
l'autoritarisme en abusant de 493 comme
en 2023 vous engagez-vous à user de cet
article ou laisser faire le débat
parlementaire monsieur le Premier
ministre c'est le gouvernement qui
détermine et conduit la politique de la
nation selon l'article 20 de la
Constitution et non le président de la
République c'est fondamental car si le
gouvernement se mu en un cabinet
d'exécutant sans vote de confiance du
Parlement c'est l'édifice institutionnel
qui s'effondre
Emmanuel Macron prend tout en main des
rencontres de Saint-Denis jusqu'à hier
lors de sa conférence de politique
générale mais il n'est pas responsable
devant le Parlement vous devez donc
Monsieur le Premier Ministre demander un
vote de confiance à l'Assemblée
nationale comme l'indique l'article 49-1
de la Constitution et au vu du rôle du
Sénat face au blocage de l'Assemblée
nationale vous devez aussi vous
soumettre à son vote en déclenchant
l'article 49-4 y compris au regard de la
place que le Sénat a pris ces derniers
temps en commission mixte paritaire
aujourd'hui c'est la confusion la
gesticulation médiatique pour masquer
l'accélération autoritaire de la
politique libérale notre peuple a besoin
de reprendre la main a besoin de clarté
à soif de justice votre mandat doit être
soumis au vote des représentants du
peuple sinon vous serez qu'illusion je
vous repose la question Monsieur le
Premier Ministre allez-vous engager la
confiance pour vous répondre la parole
est à Monsieur le Premier
Ministre merci monsieur le Président
Mesdames et Messieurs les sénatrices et
sénateurs madame la Présidente
quickerman c'est la première fois que
j'ai l'occasion de m'exprimer devant le
Sénat en tant que Premier ministre et
vous me permettrez donc de vous dire que
et je l'ai dit au président Larcher que
j'ai eu au téléphone le soir de ma
nomination nous nous sommes revus depuis
j'ai un très grand respect et même je le
dis une très grande admiration pour le
travail qui est mené ici au Sénat j'ai
pu le mesurer dans différentes fonction
gouvernemental que j'ai occupé ces
dernières années en tant que secrétaire
d'État à la Jeunesse porte-parole du
gouvernement davantage pour les
questions d'actualité des longues nuits
sur le projet de loi de finances avec le
rapporteur Husson avec le président
renal avec chacune et chacun d'entre
vous et puis au ministère de l'Éducation
nationale et de la jeun évidemment avec
le président Laffond notamment mais
aussi beaucoup d'entre vous extrêmement
mobilisés sur ces questions là j'ai
toujours été je le crois très à l'écoute
de ce qui était porté par les sénatrices
et par les sénateurs du fait de
l'expérience qui est la vôtre de la
représentativité qui est la vôre de nos
territoires dans leur très grande
diversité des propositions parfois
détonnantes et c'est aussi pour ça que
nous nous réunissons en tout cas
toujours constructive et c'est vraiment
l'état d'esprit qui m'anime et que je
poursuivrai ici avec vous j'ai eu
l'occasion de le dire je ferai ma
déclaration de politique générale à
l'Assemblée nationale le 30 janvier
prochain parce que je souhaite d'ici là
pouvoir rencontrer l'ensemble des
groupes représentés au Parlement
président de président de groupe les
forces vives de la nation les
organisations syndicales les
associations d'élus locaux je souhaite
aussi me rendre sur le terrain dans des
échanges très directs avec les Français
avant la présentation de cette
déclaration de politique générale vous
m'interrogez madame la Présidente sur
une question qui relève de l'Assemblée
nationale mais je vais évidemment y
répondre j'ai d'ailleurs et nous y avons
d'ailleurs déjà répondu est-ce qu'il y a
une majorité absolue à l'Assemblée
nationale non nous le savons est-ce
qu'il y a besoin d'un vote pour le
démontrer non je ne crois pas non plus
est-ce qu'il y a des Français qui se
lèvent le matin en se demandant est-ce
qu'il y aura ou pas un vote sur la
déclaration de politique générale du
Premier ministre je ne crois pas non
plus je pense qu'il y a des Français qui
se lèvent le matin en attendant de
savoir ce que nous allons faire pour
valoriser le travail des classes
moyennes qui sont toujours au
rendez-vous de leur responsabilités et
qui attendent qu'on agisse pour elles
pour réarmer nos services publics et
notamment l'école et la santé pour
assurer la sécurité en tout lieu sur le
territoire et pour agir pour la
transition écologique c'est ça les
préoccupations des Français et pour le
coup c'est peut-être une révélation que
je vous fais ça sera au cœur de la
déclaration de politique générale que je
ferai à l'Assemblée nationale comme
c'est vous le savez l'usage cette
déclaration sera lue ici au Sénat en
même temps que je la prononc serai à
l'Assemblée nationale mais j'ai proposé
au Président Larcher nous ne sommes pas
encore reparlés mais j'ai proposé c'est
peut-être moins l'usage de venir dans la
foulée de cette déclaration de politique
générale devant vous pour prononcer une
intervention propre au Sénat évidemment
sur les enjeux que je viens d'évoquer
qui concerne tous les
Français mais je crois que la situation
que traverse notre pays les défis que
traverse le monde et en tout cas l'état
d'esprit qui est le mien command que
nous puissions avoir un débat ensemble
ici au Sénat et c'est l'engagement que
je prends devant vous je vous remercie
[Applaudissements]
merci